two weeks ago I had a mini breakdown
with my girlfriends it turned out being
a moment where I really realized that I
needed to have a mental breakdown I had
been holding in and holding things
together for so long and so I have MS
and I've had it for 23 years almost and
for much of my journey I've been
applauded and celebrated for how strong
I am with it and I appreciate that and I
can also appreciate it about myself like
how I've dealt with it but I also think
it's been to a fault sometimes because a
lot of my being strong was just kind of
not expressing how hard it is sometimes
and being like I'm okay I'm okay I'm
okay I'm okay no wor it's fine it's fine
and it it was a moment of like it
bubbling over and just I needed to kind
of say all the things that I was afraid
to say which is this sucks and I'm angry
and I'm upset